what is radiation isn't a bad type of
poisoning it's just like a dirty word to
me this is something which is not good
not good for me being a human being
exposed to great amounts of it
waves of bad suffer yeah I mean it's
dangerous we all know that right
water is good for your radiation is not
easy it can go right through like walls
radiation can seep through the concrete
walls and so case it's absorbed into
your skin and then you get poisoning
from the radiation itself could damage
DNA
changing like I guess mutations
mutations
it ruins tissues and what none that can
break down the body and it's not healthy
it causes like cancer and things like
that are you exposed to radiation no not
at all no probably in some ways but you
don't know exactly huh no not really
from the Sun I've all Fine's they tell
us yeah they're probably from a lot of
electronic sources microwaves and things
spray yeah yeah cell phones and the
cancer-causing do you think I think they
are because um yeah I mean like a lot of
people have come up with like you know
cancer tumors around the ear area
recently and I think that's too much of
a coincidence to not be involved with
the mobile phone usage I think that it
does but I it doesn't affect my data of
daily life and we you know where I put
my phone and still carried in my pocket
even though I might get cancer my leg I
mean it's not changing my life UV rays
gamma x-rays gamma alpha beta gamma all
right let's take a closer look at these
examples they are all in fact types of
radiation assuming by mobile phones we
mean the waves that they transmit which
are microwaves but there are some
important distinctions between these and
different types of radiation for example
alpha and beta rays are actually tiny
particles moving very fast
whereas the rest of
these types of radiation are all waves
very similar to light so let's arrange
them by particles on the right and waves
on the left
another very important distinction is
between the radiation that can do damage
to molecules like DNA and radiation that
can't
so let's rearrange the radiation into
these groups so the damaging radiation
includes UV rays x-rays gamma rays and
alpha and beta particles so sunlight and
microwaves including the waves used by
mobile phones should not be able to
cause damage to molecules so where is
most of your exposure to damaging
radiation coming from well for one thing
there are radioactive isotopes in the
soil and in the air that we breathe so
we get a very low level of background
radiation from these sources also every
time we take a plane trip we're exposed
to higher levels of what's called cosmic
radiation which are particles that are
streaming towards us from outer space
normally these are blocked out by the
atmosphere but at the high altitudes
that planes flat we're exposed to more
of this radiation every time you get an
x-ray at the dentist or to check for
broken bones that also gives you a
significant dose of radiation but
generally the levels of radiation that
we're exposed to are so low that it's
not worth worrying about bananas are
radioactive why is that I'm gonna have
to put in 40 lady and so if you eat too
many bananas you can get readings up a
Geiger counter yeah do you eat bananas
I'm so far I guess it never puts you off
the thought that it can meeting could be
radiating you kind of cool to be honest
like radioactive powers with something